warum hat man schwamm gewählt weil man
wäldern und feldern weit weg von den von
geradezu vorsonntag weil es könnte
beide nicht wollte also der punkt ist
europa oder außenpolitik mit in die
prozent sind schon eine menge
den hauptstädten und ich glaube das ist
sendung obwohl das ja hier mich so oft
dass wir natürlich in deutschland noch
wirklich sein dass wir so eine art
so ein
auch so in frankreich die franzosen
donald trump in weiblich jetzt demnächst
verhältnismäßigkeit wahlrecht haben
der fall ist aber die franzosen will
bekommen ja und die wird natürlich die
jetzt am sonntag zum zweimal zweiter
weswegen sich das nicht so artikuliert
haben ein ganz anderes im
eu von innen heraus zerstören also ich
wahlgang es geht um marie le pen oder
natürlich sei es war wirklich nur ich
migrationsproblem als wir die haben
sehe nur den autismus wächst und genau
makro und es ist natürlich schon eine
finde diese frau wirklich gefährlich
richtig ghettos wo
haben das auch zu spüren und in den
deshalb handelt es sich meiner ansicht
schicksalswahl weil wir sind ja als
ländern wo ist deswegen großbritannien
die
nach hier nicht nur um eine frankreich
wester deutschland sicher partner in
usa und frankreich in ländern wo man sah
war sondern auch um eine deutschland war
dieser partnerschaft europa mit dem
kranken halt leben und und gründeten
ja schon gehört ich meine man wollte so
franzosen aufs engste verbunden ein
denn jetzt installieren
sehr dünne job nicht das lipid beiden
populistischer sozusagen wahlsieg in
wie ich ihn ja immerhin
diese außenpolitik von iris so
eigene staaten
frankreich ist sicherlich was anderes
gegründet haben und
ich habe gerade alles tatsächlich genau
als sagen wir mal ungarn oder polen ja
nationalistisch geradezu rassistisch die
da haben wir ja schon populisten in der
wissen zu lernen aber aber ich glaube
der antisemitismus ist in
hält auch gar nichts von deutschland ich
regierung aber polen und ungarn sind
glaube auch manchmal dass sie geradezu
auch ob wie hier ich finde das wort
eifersüchtig ist auf die beziehung
nicht dem euro sind relativ kleine
frankreich sehr groß die
system vertrauen ganz spannend frau guru
zwischen makro und merkel und sie sagt
länder ungarn hat acht oder zehn
millionen einwohner frankreich ist
fremdenfeindlichkeit
wann ist uns denn dieses system
ja bei jeder entscheidung die
deutschland fällt habe ich ein bisschen
die eine phobie ging gegenüber muslime
55 57 millionen das heißt es wären
vertrauen wenn sie den trend ja auch
mitleid mit ihnen also soviel zum
schon in deutschland es wird ja auch
anderer schnack ja das heißt als
all das all das füllt sie und sagt also
hier immer mehr gespalten weil es uns
stellenwert von deutschland bei ihr ja
deutscher können wir nicht sagen dass
den abhang naja also für deutschland
und dafür hat sie aber zu dem besonders
uns diese war nicht interessiert jetzt
wenn ich dann an der macht bin dann
sind die zahlen seien noch gut ja ich
gerne kontakt ihn ja genau er hat sogar
sitze ich aber auch nicht hier um zu
verschwindet das alles dann verschwindet
hab's mir deswegen auch noch mal extra
sagen also ist jetzt sozusagen die
guckt also hier haben sozusagen nur 33
ein teil ihres wahlkampfs vielen anderen
diese diesen menschen die nicht hierher
rettung für frankreich ist auch
nur hat 33 prozent der deutschen haben
ich weiß das muss man sich mal
gehören dann haben wir wieder eine echte
vorstellen und das heißt das denn dann
problematisch hat die soziale frage
französische kultur und das glaubt man
jetzt für die ukraine und sie sagt ja
kein vertrauen mehr in staat und
vernachlässigt mein punkt hier ist das
regierung nur an regierung 16 prozent
auch ich weiß nicht ob wir dann noch in
einfach wenn man nicht in der hauptstadt
der nato sind was heißt das denn da so
schwierige an dieser wahl ist dass es
haben noch vertrauen in die regierung
und dann der eine satz noch und der ist
eigentlich keine wahl ist er und zwar
lebt glaubt man das glaube ich sehr
regierung ist schlimmer als staat aber
für deutschland natürlich relevant sie
schon zum zweiten mal das nämlich
gerne und ein anderes phänomen nicht
hat vor zwei drei tagen ein
dass wir sozusagen noch ein
eigentlich immer nur dieses system
grundsätzliches institutionen vertrauen
zeitungsartikel veröffentlicht ja da
sehr bindet mehr und ein gemeinsamer
kollision entsteht dass da einer jetzt
steht drin wenn sie gewählt wird möchte
haben dass haben bei uns nur 33 prozent
feind er punktet auch immer alte mutter
sozusagen nämlich makatsch und 2017
sie hat es sogenannt die
stellt sich immer sehr stark als mutter
nicht mehr in frankreich sind es über 60
deutsch-französische scheidung ja
jetzt nochmal frankreich vor marine le
in den vordergrund und sagt ich werde
vermutlich das ja das würde ja weil das
was sagen sie frankreich sind zwei
pen retten muss tja und das nennt man in
drittel die nicht mehr wir haben nur ein
für eure gleichstellung kämpfen und
frankreich dann frauen repubblica also
die deutsch französische freundschaft
sondern rech hatte noch nie eine
sei illusionär gewesen hätte frankreich
drittel und das ist echt ein problem ist
alle müssen jetzt ob sie wollen oder
präsidentin auch das könnte punkte für
nicht makro wählen damit marie le pen
nur geschadet
dass die glaubwürdigkeit der politiker
nicht regiert das ist natürlich für die
sie geben aber ich glaube vor allem auf
in dem kontext der wahl ja und da wir
dem dorf stellung auf dem land wo man
französische linke fast inakzeptabel vor
die einfach nicht mehr die einfachen
einfach sagt wir wollen alle probleme
allen dingen zum zweiten mal das heißt
nicht mehr glaubwürdig sind die nicht
jetzt ja nächstes jahr im januar
eigentlich 60 jahre élysée vertrag
eine wahl die sich eigentlich in einem
die man die man in frankreich auf dem
verantwortung übernehmen die ihre
politischen spektrum abspielen sollte
feiert also deutsch französische
land zu glaubt zu spüren hängen den
freundschaft ist das natürlich eine
meinung mal ganz schnell ändern wenn es
rechts links konservativ grünen wie auch
ankündigung die eigentlich jeden in
immer wird zu einer wahl zwischen system
die zeitenwende erfordert wo sollen denn
irgendeiner form mit ausländern zusammen
diesem lande also in deutschland in
diesem fall zucken lassen müsste weil
ja
verteidigen gegen systemkritik das ist
da der normale bürger vertrauen haben
die besitzen unsere jobs die machen sich
deutschland frankreich scheidung was
als solches im prinzip schon so eine
also in frankreich nicht das monocoque
heißt das für europa dh wir sind
erosion von demokratie um mal zwei
hier breit die zerstören unsere kultur
tatsächlich wir wären tatsächlich
ja es gibt viele gründe es gibt geld
zahlen zu nennen es haben über 60
betroffen im mag auch unserer sozusagen
die belästigen unsere frauen ja das sind
westen soziale gründe in frankreich die
prozent der franzosen kein vertrauen
staatsräson eigentlich immer fragen was
stadt land spaltung also wenigen städte
das sind ganz primitive reaktionen und
mehr in ihre regierung und in ihren
fasziniert die menschen denn an frau le
lyon paris die funktionieren mit urban
staat also kein system vertrauen und bei
die haben dann macht sich
eliten und das land drumherum
pen sehr man sieht halt gesagt dass
steuerversprechen und kaufte sich so
den ganzen anderen waren die wir gesehen
menschen geschichten leben die im netz
spritpreise alles ist dann thema
auch noch stimmen es geht auch um die eu
haben in frankreich also regional waren
gehen menschen lieben menschen das haben
migration großes thema seit langem also
kommunalwahlen sind teilweise bei den
landwirtschaftspolitik welches ja und
sie auch beim groß und gesagt was ist
über rassismus antisemitismus alles
letzten kommunalwahlen 2020 60 prozent
der eu landwirtschaftspolitik hat viel
dieses dieses jahr die marine le pen
drauf ja gerade auf dem land hat
nicht zur wahl gegangen so das heißt man
kaputtgemacht also sowohl die milchkühe
lebendige punktgenau ist er überall hin
ich glaube das liegt auch wirklich an an
kann gar nicht mehr ermessen dass die
der normandie aber auch unten die
aprikosen und die ganzen 40 anbauten ja
franzosen von ihrem system praktisch
gewinnern in die dörfer hat sich über
schon genervt sind ja so dass der
all blicken lassen hat extrem stark auf
der ländlichen bevölkerung das ist ja
und wenn sie so ein französischer bauer
sind und von der eu
wahlgang fast schon zwei mal ein kleiner
ähnlich wie bei trump ja also in
die frauen gesetzen und makro hat sich
landwirtschaftspolitik enttäuscht sind
trend der sich doch abseits so ist noch
washington und new york hätte niemand
und dann kommt marie le pen und sagt ich
dort nämlich nicht blicken lassen er war
in deutschland wenn ich das so sagen
angenommen dass trump gewinnt das hat
bin gegen die eu das ist auch noch ein
darf nicht wirklich anders in den usa
gerade noch arrogant und ist nicht
man ja nicht geglaubt trump war der ist
tresor zu boden wir werden auf jeden
aufgetreten deshalb hat sie jetzt ein
vorteil ja und 35.000 kommunen sind 22
er ist der heroin in den irgendwo in den
fall das thema es ist ihm vertrauen hier
nicht aus den augen verlieren damit es
hatte in der ersten wahl an marie lippe
in deutschland niemals so weit kommt wie
und ich habe heute mit einer freundin
in frankreich ich finde nämlich schon 33
telefoniert aus paris und ich zittere
[Gelächter]